just tell you I think a few words about
some open problems of course as you
might have noticed the big open problem
we've discussed this generalized X
conjecture the question hyperbolic
programming and semi definite
programming compare and detail and I've
brought a few more sort of more
elementary looking at least open
problems that I also put on the exercise
sheet so a problem that I mentioned that
I am quite curious about i personally
don't
we'll see so the element is I mentioned
this already I would very much like to
know you look at the second order cone
what is the smallest determinant
representation that this has mean we
have seen this thing you can write one
down explicitly
so which means that the size of the
determinant representation here is of
size n plus one it's unclear that this
is optimal I think it's open
even for silly cases like N equals three
there's a choice doesn't believe me
disprove Pablo I challenge you to write
down so even here right the one you
write down is 4x4
it cannot be 2x2 just for rank reasons
not clear to me that it cannot be 3x3 in
some mysterious way even this example
and we just don't have any good
techniques to show such lower bound
really determine the size of these
majors this is sort of innocent-looking
problem it's so innocent-looking that
Pablo believes it should be easy I know
but even these simple I essentially want
representation of his form you're
allowed to homogenize to some degree and
then write one down so I only allow you
just this as a cofactor and that sort of
the same as writing a determinant a
representation of larger size of this TV
to modernize you will just get an extra
factor of the homogenizing variable of
course is you sure if you admit
cofactors you might be able to do even
better and get the size even lower which
in this example I don't quite believe
but I don't have a good reason maybe
even that interesting but the smallest
size of a determinant representation is
just I think of fun elementary problem
that might be an informative of how we
should prove such things in general be
nice set right félicité common is the
ball
yes
that's this question about powers so how
could two powers do so we have seen
Pettis County example shows that you
cannot always take the cofactor to be a
power of the polynomial itself and I
have reason to believe that if you look
at the set of all hyperbolic polynomials
this is homogeneous of fixed degree D
such that the power there exists some
power e to the K symmetric mental
representation as a subset of this
vector
I believe this is not a zero effect
believe that this has non empty interior
except and I think nobody has written it
down but I believe should not be
unsolvable I think you can do so at
least it would not be a zero set for
which powers work even if they don't
work in general
question I like and I think it's not him
I think this is open because nobody sat
down and did it it's not too hard to
decide
- Apollo from Berlin
like matrix there's only one direction
power has a definite determinant to
representation then this matrix will be
a square
right so I believe this to be true has
non-empty teria
and I believe it's not too hard okay
sort of a classification sort of you
know Hilbert's theorem in village by
geometry then open problem number three
on this sheet might remind you of that
so the question is sometimes so fix the
number of variables and fix the degree
and ask the question does every
polynomial hyperbola polynomial every
year to exist the power that has one
right for some small values this might
be true in general it's false like
degree four and four variables may be
you can classify the values of number of
variables and degree for which this
holds and the interesting cases I think
are in particular the most interesting
case is in four variables and dq3 exist
a power
[Music]
every year I write down quantifiers this
is English
so for every hyperbolic polynomial
exists the power may be P to decay has a
definite
particularly interesting cases cubics
and four variables it could still be
true we don't have a couch example it
could also be false
nobody has decided this case yet so it's
the smallest interesting one
therefore in three variables the hell
Dominica theorem that's not interesting
in degree - it's a theorem by andrea
storm internet so it's a non trivial
fact that the power of every quadric has
a definite determinant we know it in
degree two and for three variables so
maybe that's the interesting case that's
probably left that does counterexample
what about cubic sin for babe so that I
think would also be doable if you
and then apparently my last question is
not open anymore even though I wasn't
aware of it so the complexity of testing
hypervelocity
félicité of a polynomial in a fixed
direction
and the discussion suggests that this is
known to be np-hard but I don't know a
reference and
have one Leventis appears they seem to
know this
maybe this is not open anymore baby
anyway I haven't seen a paper yet that
asked and I think it's just relevant to
know what the complexity status really
we've seen some approaches have how you
could Mason's numerically test these
things but
yesterday's and I think the expectation
is that it's hot nobody will be
surprised if you prove that it's hard
but you know somebody so there's my list
of open questions that I have here if
you are interested we can show I can
find more for you all of them all and
get four during the program let me know
I grab lunch and be upstairs if you want
to discuss the homework problems
probably had one something second floor
and we can chat about question solutions
problems progress
there's a that's a homogeneous
polynomial this is hyperbolic with
respect to the vector all ones in the X
directions and zeros look at any of the
restrictions along this direction you
literally get the matching polynomial of
some sub graph of G so if I haven't made
this rebooted and
me Mohini has proven that the code
corresponding to this polynomial is
tetrahedral
but the dimension required is about n
factorial this comes from Godzilla rules
with the southward across tree and so on
and so one cupcake question is can you
prove can you prove along on the side
the spectral representation of this tone
and I guess we'll already discuss that
you know using T's in you formulate it
housebreak it seems to be very difficult
it may also be difficult using other
techniques but there are techniques to
pioneer when the store for proving lower
bounds of extension complexity of convex
sets a very analytic technique and okay
interesting to see it what happens if
you try to foil or dis apply it would be
an example of a being explicit example
of an actually quite interesting code
which has very high complexity if you
represent it is optimizing is not
equivalent to ICP yourself no I mean if
this mean explicit example were which is
interesting where the ball would have to
be
smaller size will be too
in this example and you can see yeah
that's true yeah but then even have miss
any more variables is also much you
can't get hermitian sighs - if the rank
of the quadratic form is greater than 4
and if you want a mission then let me
put N equals 4 for the hermitian
challenge tweak my parameters to make it
an open problem
the last line just lower bound okay pull
over
[Applause]